foreign
it's easy to tell when someone's not
paying attention but it can be
surprisingly tricky to know what truly
excellent listening looks like
behavioral scientists have found that
good listening is one of the most
important things we can do to improve
our relationships develop our world view
and potentially even change people's
minds so what can we do to become better
listeners
at its core listening in a one-on-one
conversation is about taking an interest
in another person and making them feel
understood there's no universally agreed
upon definition of high quality
listening but some recurring features
include attentiveness conveying
understanding and showing a positive
intention towards the speaker this
doesn't mean you can simply go through
the motions researchers have found that
merely smiling and nodding at set
intervals doesn't quite work however
there is something slightly performative
about listening in that it's important
to show you're doing it so in addition
to actively attending to a speaker's
words good listeners also use questions
and body language that indicate their
understanding and their desire to
understand
this might feel awkward at fast and
what's most effective might depend on
your relationship with the speaker but
with time and practice you can
internalize these basic behaviors
so let's say a good friend wants to tell
you about an issue they're having with
their partner
before even starting your conversation
remove any distractions in the
environment turn off the TV take off
your headphones and put your phone away
far away
one study showed that even the visible
presence of a phone made conversations
feel less intimate and fulfilling to
those involved
once the conversation begins one of the
most important things you can do is also
the most obvious try not to interrupt
this doesn't mean you need to stay
completely silent but if you do
interject look for natural pauses to ask
open-ended questions that benefit the
speaker not just your curiosity
questions like what happened next or how
did that make you feel confirm that
you're following the story while also
helping the speaker dive deeper into
their own thoughts another great way to
show your understanding is by
summarizing what you just heard and
asking if you've missed anything
summaries like these show the speaker
that you're truly trying to understand
them rather than just waiting for your
turn to talk
speaking of which while a good
conversation requires back and forth
planning out your response while a
speaker is talking is a common way to
miss what's being said
so try to stay present and if you lose
focus don't be shy about asking the
speaker to repeat what you missed this
might feel embarrassing but asking for
clarification actually shows that you're
committed to understanding
finally don't be afraid of Silence it's
okay to ask for a moment to formulate
your response and taking a beat to think
can help speakers reflect on their
speech as well
these might seem like small changes but
together they make a big difference and
when people feel heard they report more
satisfaction trust and connection in
their relationships in the workplace
employees who feel heard generally
experience less burnout and perceive the
managers who listen to them more
favorably
unfortunately while it might be easy to
listen to some people it can be hard to
muster all this focus and attention if
you disagree with or dislike the speaker
but these situations might actually
benefit most from your efforts to listen
openly
the theory of Psychological reactants
suggests that trying to force someone to
change their mind makes them more likely
to defend their point of view however
recent studies suggest that high quality
listening Fosters open-mindedness by
creating a non-judgmental and
psychologically safe environment
of course truly open-minded listening
isn't about changing people's minds good
listening is not the same as agreeing
and conversations don't have to end with
a happy resolution
but even during a disagreement sometimes
being heard is enough to start a deeper
conversation
so what happens if you can't connect to
someone or Worse what happens if they
reject you learn what makes rejection
such a uniquely painful experience and
how to work through it with this video
or get more actionable science-based
advice on how to build character at
ed.ted.com forward slash build character